جديد هذا الصباح علمت شبكة سي إن إن أن
المحققين الفيدراليين يبحثون في
هجوم إلكتروني واضح بعد
أن حاول المتسللون سرقة بيانات حساسة من
عدة مقاولين
دفاعيين أمريكيين من بين قطاعات رئيسية أخرى سي إن إن لينجوس
تعيش مع أحدث المعلومات حول هذا
الأمر ، ما الذي تعلمته هنا  حسناً
ما تعلمناه أنه أه في
الأسابيع العديدة الماضية أه
متسللين أجانب أطلقوا عدة
محاولات اقتحام
لنا مقاولين دفاعيين أه شركات في
قطاع الطاقة وفي أماكن أخرى في الولايات
المتحدة وفي دول أخرى كذلك وما
زال الوقت مبكراً  قل من يقف
وراء هذا بالضبط ولكن البحث الذي تمت
مشاركته معي وأن وكالة الأمن القومي
والتي تبحث عنها درهم
تشير إلى أنه من الممكن أن تكون
مجموعة قرصنة صينية ولكننا لم
نؤكد ذلك بعد ، فما الذي
يبحثون عنه؟  ما هي نقاط الضعف
هنا جيدًا التي يستخدمها المتسللون أه
يقومون بمسح الإنترنت بحثًا عن
برامج ضعيفة ومن ثم
يختارون أهدافًا من قاعدة بيانات ضخمة  مجموعة من
الأهداف المحتملة لتضييق نطاق
البيانات الحساسة من المؤسسات التي
يريدون هذا هو جهد تجسس كلاسيكي
ومن هناك يتعمقون
أكثر في شبكات الكمبيوتر
لمحاولة الوصول إلى رسائل البريد الإلكتروني المحتملة
وغيرها من المعلومات ، ما الذي يمكن أن
أقصده  إذا كنت تتحدث عن قطاع الطاقة ،
فهل يمكنهم إغلاق الأمور بشكل
محتمل أم لا في هذه الحالة ، فهذا
ليس الهدف أم هذا هو أه مجرد
تجسس ويركز على
الاتصالات بين
الشركات الحساسة وعملاء الحكومة
المحتمل